ساعات تحبس الانفاس وانظار العالم تترقب
انقاذ الغواصه السياحيه المفقوده منذ
الاحد الماضي يبحث خبر السواحل الامريكي
عن اي اشاره او همسه لكن مع مرور كل دقيقه
تتضائل الاعمال في العثور عليها وربما
تحتاج لمعجزه فيما تحاول فرق الانقاذ رصد
اي صوت في سبيل انقاذ طاقم الغواصه كفر
السواحل الامريكيه اعلن ان طائرات كنديه
رصدت اصواتا تحت الماء خلال عمليات البحث
عن الغواصه المفقوده منذ الاحد الماضي
والتي كانت تحمل على متنها خمسه اشخاص
مشيرا الى انه تم نقل عمليات اليه موجهه
عن بعد لمحاوله تقصي مصدر هذه الاصوات الى
ان النتائج كانت سلبيه لكن الجهه المسؤوله
ما زالت تواصل البحث واكد خبر السواحل
الامريكي في بيان خلال مؤتمر صحفي في
بوسطن ان الاكسجين المتبقي في الغواصه
يكفي لحوالي 40 ساعه منذ اعلانها يوم
الثلاثاء الماضي واوضح البيان ان عمليات
البحث ما زالت معقده للغايه ولم يبدو ان
لعنه تايتنك اصابت تايتنك لكن الامل موجود
وانت ضال والعالم باتا ينتظر المعجزه اي
خروج الغواصه ونجاه ركابها
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات